nous sommes à la chapelle glain en loire
atlantique pour y rencontrer olivier
bellion il fait partie des 20 millions
de français concernés par la pauvreté et
des 4 millions de mal logés
bonjour merci nous accueillir chez vous
olivier depuis plus de trois ans vous
habiter ici alors vous êtes gravement
malade et vous habiter dans un logement
insalubre
dans quelles conditions vous vivez au
quotidien c'est très désagréable vu mon
état d'avoir des remontées comme ça des
goûts et d'extrêmement est en fait je
paye un loyer de plus de 1 100 euros
pour vivre les pieds dans la merde quoi
tout le temps même l'hiver obligé
d'ouvrir les fenêtres tellement ça sent
mauvais il fait froid j'ai un poil
derrière vous à gad c'est trois
bouteilles de gaz par semaine à 40 euros
la bouteille plus les bougies tout enfin
si vous comptez tout c'est un budget qui
me coûte à peu grosse et cher que le
loyer quoi ces 400 450 euros entre du
bougies le gaz et les autres produits
pour les odeurs quoi est ce que je peux
dire excusez moi du terme que vous vivez
dans des grandes toiles est votre maison
sont des toilettes je compare plutôt ma
maison une fosse septique en fait je
vide je paye un loyer de plus de 500
euros pour pourvus pour ville dans une
fosse septique oui depuis bientôt quatre
ans
et donc ils ont mis les fumigènes comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure et c'est
comme ça partout
bas derrière les tuyaux c'est pareil les
fumigènes et la fumée armand qui fait
que même en tous les leviers de la
cuisine ce kiss ou pas la fumée au
prince qui m'expliquait par où passait
fumigènes passe les mauvaises odeurs
donc partout dans la maison et des
mauvaises odeurs qui remonte partout
adjointe
mais pas trop le battage fait que mary j
l'opus sema show du crazy contrer ces
désagréments qui remonte par ici cic
s'est plaint mais ça déborde il y en a
partout ça arrive que dans couloir voyez
comme vous poussez s'ouvrir tout le
temps tout en rien obligé chez obligée
là je ferme tout l'été pour passer dans
l'une r gt1 les bougies vous tenez pas
dans la maison barbu voyez comment
malheureusement je suis malade 1 quand
vous vous levez à 2 heures du matin et
tout pour nettoyer tout ça bien croyez
moi que ce n'est pas viable vous recevez
votre enfant dans ces conditions ben moi
maintenant parce que j'ai pas envie
qu'ils sont malades surtout société
laquelle un
mondial et des gaz qui était dangereux
qui était même très dangereux pour la
santé
olivier c'est quand même assez
incroyable assez insensé que vous vous
sentiez plus à l'aise dehors en plein
mois de décembre à moins 20 degrés avec
votre bouteille d'oxygène dans votre
jardin que vous soyez mieux à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur va tout à
fait c'est meilleur pour moi ça sent sa
samba ça sent pas les extrêmement ni
belle ni la mère ni pour pour être clair
on savait même pas la visite de vos
enfants quoi dans ces circonstances là
du tout non non non non non ce ne soit
pas grand monde à part l'infirmière est
ce que vous regrettez
d'avoir emménagé dans cette maison il ya
quatre ans all que oui et j'ai pas les
moyens de passer par une agence
immobilière ou par des particuliers quoi
quand vous êtes reconnu e adultes
handicapés avec à peine 900 euros par
mois une fois vous payer votre loyer à
500 mal et vous asseyez des bougies du
des simples il faut attendre en tout ce
que je peux dire mais oui mais j'ai même
écrit
madame sophie kluzek et ministre des
gens handicapés jamais eu de réponse
notre ancien premier ministre monsieur
edouard philippe
jamais eu de réponses on vu je dois pas
quelqu'un intéressant de toute façon et
puis le par rapport à toute façon on
n'existe pas ou peu si vous aviez un mot
à dire aux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ce serait lequel
ces gens là premièrement je pense qu'ils
voient déjà le fauteuil de la place et
le pouvoir donc tous tous pareil pour
moi ça donne pas envie d'aller voter en
fait que vous allez voter pour quelqu'un
en ayant certaines convictions et
certaines idées et une fois qu'ils sont
pas si ils font rien ça m'étonne pas
qu'ils aient autant de gens qui vont
plus voter il occupa des gens